yeah welcome to a to a video I'm to do
video yet just then something stupid to
just happen to me I after I only scored
two draws out of four games and lost the
last game terribly I simply forgot to to
press the record button before I started
the new game so I played this game and
did all the comentary and then I
recognized okay I spoke to no one not to
my microphone not to anyone so the live
recording yeah got lost so to say but it
was a pretty nice on finish of the game
so I like to show it quickly to at least
have one win for today on video opponent
was called the goat to 250 rated or
something okay um let's go let's go
quickly through the game um we got a
Catalan opening and just normal mamamoo
SIA and he went for the closer variation
here and now with 94 he M invites
transposition to stonewall which we got
okay I don't want to go in detail on
food through all the moves that the end
was really the main point yeah GG
forearm yeah looked strange to me
because I get to nice posts now for the
night for the night so Kirk he's got e4
but while he 5 it for just tremendous on
squares okay I wanted to open up the H
file maybe get the bishop to f3 kingi to
Luke h1 and get something going on the
edge file and now he surprised me with
taking here
and not G for the f3 is not not good
here you can take on e3 and this is so
at best it's a mess so I played solid
move and now King edge 8 and I couldn't
resist you two went to go for this year
if it takes now with the with you pawn i
have e six check and the diagonal gets
opened up I think he needs to interpose
something and this is just just a
terrible position I don't even have a
material sacrificed for this and this
diagonal would be worth a lot so white
is just clearly better maybe maybe even
maybe even winning if he's if he's
careful okay played rook c8 and now i
have lab problems with the Queen Queen
this attacked and I don't want to go to
e2 or d3 because of Bishop b5 I went
here just to show quickly if I go here
or you two E's got this oops it's got
this annoying move don't want that so I
went back to d1 i played this anyway but
now the queen is not detect so i can
take on g4 um he took it on f1 the idea
was if he recaptures i have this move
and the queen is hanging night is
hanging so maybe needs to take and now
has a strong threat here is f7 and what
should be winning here the long diagonal
gets open to sits just a disaster so it
took f1 and now Knight f6 just similar a
point for Queen B five now
if he takes is just just very similar
threat and f7 and also threatened bishop
h 5v for instance tries to block this i
can go here and then f seven plus with
the win so you went for Queen B 5 in
this position now I took here you
recaptured our new form i will now I
have a simple win but IM plea was too
tempted to take on e6 I to talk on e6
now I can just I can just capture here
and and win easily just I just have
extra material here to to to bishops and
also this one is still u6 still terribly
weekend hanging and it's just as just
over this would be very simple win but I
was alright planned Bishop e-cigs and Su
um probably already accustomed to I
didn't have much time so I went for this
now plate Bishop e2 and now the best
move from is Queen D 6 which is also
winning instantly with the idea of
Bishop e6 somewhere Bishop c4 maybe with
the tempo and then e-cigs check opening
up the bishop on b2 which is really a
monster piece but I didn't have much
time and played this year and now he
actually could have gotten um maybe
playable position with 23 but you played
this Queen D 3 was much much tougher
move to to crack okay played rook c to d
8 and now i have the very nice move
Queen d6 now I saw it I didn't see it
one move before if it takes now you
played this it takes now it's just check
mate while I can can interpose a couple
of things but it's checkmate with the 22
brilliant bishops here and I just
threatened to move the bishop and play
60 we simply cannot do anything against
this he played Bishop f3 we should see
for he now took here so um if I would
recapture you would actually be able to
take here because he now has got the
scroungy aid but i have e 6 check King
g8 and 25 and now we cannot cover g7
made and h8 mate so it's a just made
next move or in a couple of moves you
can do some Desperados stuff lag between
c1 and group d 1 and so on but it's just
just a maid on g7 no h8 so this was the
strongest bishop that I had in a while
okay i just wanted to show this nice
furniture it's a shame that it didn't
get to the live video okay well thanks
forum for watching and make sure to
leave questions or comments here or i
guess see over the weekend for a couple
of new videos see ya